pleased to be joined once again here on
this program by the Pro Football Hall of
Famer Packer legend Super Bowl champion
but most importantly dad and grandfather
he is Brett Favre here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Brett
I'm good rich how you doing I am doing
fine you know you you say something unto
a radio interview and if you know he
goes they go absolutely bananas so again
so so what's this about how to call you
up to find out what's going on you want
to coach or be a general manager in the
NL No
okay uh what I Sunday who knows okay I
can rule anything else sure you know I
when I left a football I came home of
the high school coach here at Oak Grove
a good guy great friend a legend here in
the state had asked me if I wanted to be
the Austin's coordinator for 15 years I
bet he said when you retired Brett I
went to be Boston's coordinator and I
always joked I said yeah okay you know
uh
but he he kind of strong-armed me into
doing it uh and I had a blast I guess my
point is I'll never say never but but
right now I'm going to place my life I
do not want this any games that month
our youngest daughter plays in
volleyball and my my grand I got two
grandsons and I got one on the way and
that's was always oldest daughter
Brittany whose lawyer here in town was
doing well you know I just don't want to
miss any that stuff and to be a coach to
be a GM requires a tremendous amount of
time away from your family I just don't
want that now if I was ever in a
position where I could I could make the
decisions and and I'm not going to stay
here to twelve o'clock at night or two
in the morning you know you know if
that's what it takes for me to be your
coach GM I'm just not going to do it I
mean never I'm just not going to do that
it's not worth it to lose the time with
my family
Brett Favre joining me here on the show
so what I guess then what what it's do
you have on that front
what do you enjoy about
it for the idea about it Brett okay well
I don't know really the only thing I
think if it's what I've always done not
not coach but football and I'm really
not good anything else come on yes you
know I mean yes that's what I was born
to do and I do feel like Indiana would
be the first to say this and I think the
two years that I coached high school now
you know we're talking about high school
football here for sure but the two years
that I coached there in the fact that
it's what I've done my whole life I feel
like if I don't give back in some some
way shape or form that that I'm wasting
a lot of you know experience and an
information that I can pass along yes
and I noticed that when I coached those
two years my schooling and on by the way
one of the kids I coach there's going to
be a starting receiver for four cow
Jordan Duncan will be in the second year
out of cow receivers great cheer so you
guys need to look him up okay and pay
attention uh you know and what you know
I think about that kid I think about
many others just for kids that start for
Southern Miss now um and then there's
numerous others that went off the plate
somewhere else
and I felt like I made a difference in
her life you know that maybe had I not
Coast I wouldn't give them that edge if
that makes sense
and so the downside of high school you
know the upside is the limited amount of
time the I could I could drive five
minutes be there five minutes home no
big deal
the downside would be you really can't
expand that your you know your database
with these kids and you know you can't
be too creative I mean you can be but
you know you didn't want high school
kids who are not exposed to a lot of
things and part of that is good so I
feel like you know you go up to the next
level and then the next level after that
there's pros and cons and and all that
so we were so
for those of us in the in the media
Brett in the paparazzi who were hoping
that we would have a shot of you in a
luxury suite all suited and booted like
Elway all nervous watching the game
that's not happening we're not going to
get now okay what about now first of all
I don't know how to dress up on how to
tie a tie and probably you know
interviews our report at the ANA gives
me a hard time when I make breakfast for
the family she gives me a hard time she
says Brett the presentation was not very
good make sure the food was and I said
what are you talking about she goes you
can't serve fruit and an omelet and a
pancakes on a paper plate with plastic
forks I'm like why not
she goes just put them on a good play
give them a real fork so my point is I
go into an interview I'm going to be me
that may be okay with a lot of people
but some old and they say you know I
don't want this Jake leg running my
organization that doesn't mean I
couldn't do it or wouldn't be great at
it but I'm just gonna be mean and and
that makes a lot of people off what do
you think home bring thought of when the
news might have passed his ears
yesterday that you were thinking of
being a coach Brett I think he didn't he
didn't think twice about it he probably
said hey puppy yeah I think he he Papa
just laughed at all no but I mean you
definitely have because I was able to
follow three more minutes I was just to
get Brett up I'll be off in a with you
in a couple minutes I know you got going
on in your life but you're here well I
mean because I was just throwing this
out yesterday Andy Reid is got a guy in
Patrick mahomes who is a lot like you
from what people say Mandy told me you
know and so what if he reached out to
you to have you help coach him I would
that would be an awesome thing to do but
it's but I'm not because that means I'm
going to be missing you know people the
best time with my daughter and she's
going to be a freshman here in the fall
here southern myths you sign the
scholarships play volleyball and the and
I could not be more excited so I don't
want to miss that you know i mean i i i
think i really believe i could do a
great job at i don't want to know if I'd
say grooming or whatever you want to
really just kind of the lessons that
I've learned the do's and don'ts I been
fortunate to play with some great
players but more importantly I had some
some unbelievable coaches at the right
time in my career and you know I didn't
know at all I think I you know as I look
back I was pretty naive
it was probably served me well but there
was a big benefit in just not knowing
what the odds were and just kind of
being an all shucks
type guy just you know bring it on but
there are some tricks to the trade that
I think I can pass along you know and I
feel like that I need to do that at some
point when I have no idea okay last one
for you Brett do we see you in Canton
you come back to Canton this year your
plans fast you know what the and I
talked about last night we're going to
try to come back for the gold Jack you
know there's a lot of things going on
that week of course mmm and we can't
make everything because actually really
starts her you know if she's playing if
she's not red shirted she'll be playing
during that week they'll play the first
game so you know and I'm kind of
conflicted I wanted to play but I'd like
for the red shirt and gained an extra
year of experience you know you know you
I mean it's it's not about me anymore
it's about her and it's about the
grandkids and it's really it's really a
cool place and that's that's really
where we are right now but hey I hope to
see it that jacket dinner I'm emceeing
it again it's as you know a real special
nights I hope else which I hope to see a
life that are moved by the way thanks
look I will take that and I will run to
the bank with that breath thanks for
calling it I which I thought was it you
same that's Brett Favre the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
your stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy